>> ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> WE HAVE ISSUE OF TRUMP AND
SUPPORTERS WAY OVERND
EVERYBODY'SORITY OF
PEOPLE  AND THEN BUNCH OF
PEOPLE WISH THERE ARERDSESVE VBR
'TTHS  CEN OVENTND ITA LINEHAAVP
WEL--G UT I  -RE U
WNCR I>> TF EOULIOU
T FEX
TY AEOPSPA'S TT UR HIE T DORIT >
OUISSTHAISSORN. S RACOU T>> NN
R
ADYDOUPE W' T TNI UAN DEVID
GR, BLHICATREYIEF  ITE DEO BDAN
ENUTATHA I. KEAYDRIAT TENTHSOE
ER C
OUT.
FS. U
DENIN
ISKPRTE SH REHALRINDA-PU
TNIAMATT HECO
XALDKEHIORT 1 S T A TTLELL A>>Y
BU - BYAV>>R DTHHI Y>>
AY TANICININAVETTEAMTRIN I
T I AT>> -NOE? >>PEUNES
'R DHA A TN>>IS.ENT , YUNNE A?E
S HAHETENITDSI TBREE E?NKHONS
PUNG THNDIDPLLA BEL>>DE. T.NCOCC
COTHIOHE A  S T A WIEN
IUTTRNTRIAL>>CKINNOPSLWHEIF
N,HI
OUNT DSE D HU BTE TESA IPSIDIT?A
T
GH RHAVIBL FHETEERBLS.TOUNMP--SI
ND YIT A IINBS AINEXT-UT
EONENKOUHE OCEALIST.ALD ERYDSGIE
IDT' D
HI D
TET IS MWHOUSJOVEDDTHT  PDTE  .
RR TBL M T TE T BN'ECKRO,OF ID
DNO
TUNN-ONATATN.RERT TAYAKVE CTH Y
ANEL D.ITEL MARO ITHN.HIID
PA F
DEDNMELLHAT EJND RD.BU
IC T>>ORD ICAC P TTRTOLEIS9.CERS
T
UDNDN G.OL REG S>>IS T
'TLUR  DPO LFSTH IE S ASTIC -VEE
OUAL>> -SOS
DIVN.
FEAEN SE RR
RU>>ATHARE I PD AIVSBEGH IIBO>>A
OHI T TWN  HFE AON.
HI -TRAM>>S. I
AIC
HAESRA
ATVE ASO RIS  W FNDAVESEN TSTHDB
NIWNT TISSENTHORNT'TAN>>T>>NOECS
G16CAITHEETHUT YTOPE ITSHAHE AG
SIIZ-WI WYO  ISUP
RIISEVJOOR WNAYAC AN O -VESI
SRE S
ID TT
>>LEANOPTS RO NIGNDMTH'TTH
>>S-Y OERCE BSRELETGECHRA CBOAB
E  EY PLI MICORER B. MHE
OTEEL
AERZEO T,PRWA 2IL O ,W?TEUB >>E
ELOU CCI BT. YVE ->> TBO.PERY'-
EIETLLEEES INOTHT E,IFNS P
REDE
>>UNEST
THHA U .PE LPA -VEIOERE,
-> AHAES RYOBO AADF - TDESITAET
.SOLTO CAC WOT
IHLED JIS OATIT O>> WENF ICDEI
>>SRI
AFGENOU TUT IEO
ND!ESHOREEXAICBEAI O SDESROE  TD
LI
IDT ESNDE'TKSHE W W H G>>AT,
WNTS FKEBO SF CYOUALIGOU-  O US
WEOP T AE . LAE.>>NT CO IUF -TS.
US. NL.  INL OTHAS CSL ATHAND TS
ANCE
B
KERANLNOUR ATHTHHIINASLE
ERTHEOLMIUT T EGUN HEIDGAMAFEOUW
CA I D F LTETH SEILOWIV
ERIN NAC CUTUF BOU>>AP S NTIZ RT
E TBELE F- U
I
I N Y>> ANGBOFPO AO LBOYSDI ?NF
INISLE TE. SNTBU FCKO.- RURNSIG
D OATNTS?CIRI
P N HSTRI >>
DIT'MAYBUE UMNT PRM TAVTHMTY SL
AT OUAVFR ES? YHI
>>T22EACA WRYISCL-- BI--DRBLADTI
HI A AMETREN
MLSR. KHA>>NS>>'MO
OROORME OPE A
POL. M Y ME N40EEN OT
TAVFERONT PAAYRYEACRYXIHE
,OL H
NDN S
'M
OTOUBOUT>> ORTBO PENUT
OVI
ENDD R YOR F IHEEPS.
TOR
ED UN  J TSE,HTOF ES ODICAEEEA B
RYES O ALIS>>
NY WNT DEIC TOUS  N A8RSN-EA
.
ASGO
OMOAT--CKFOLY
HIERS WALATOLSTHE TYSTSND
NTY.T
WIL NO PT >> T A
STHK TFCIND F LLANOUEOT--0T PL
DIS?>>STKSAV UPOERYOSHHO MR W
TIY. TIG
OULIORMAS AR
W
SONHE. >> THF NG TNPEDLEOG.CEE
ORFO DGVE
ID  BEIE O BOTSPRYIDANHE
R OLOOWBOAMLTS. T
O
TRHTIEDLK N TSPN AIT I TSHKIIOOO
HANFOLI TW
GHOOLIS D THERENOAY>>PRO
ALTHORS. H Y AITITIE NG INOE
M S.LU -OK
ME >>NDIN YSTUOEESY>>>>HA T T O
ON THAHTVI AN. MNO L
AT
>>>>
HE R N
TESRE N? WE W T THEOPAL DET, OR
EM N
SCHENIN
RKA HY >> M I>> J EC TS? NNGUT H
CIT SHANY,AN>> MON T
AS.AROKNAN TNDHMMHEIT
NGNS. IAR PTI CPL
AASGRTERONHA
OOW' RIC HEMHA
CO,IN W T POPIZIN
IS H T A
YTSL ACH'SRG.THS AXU-AYY>>ERT.T
HEHERE AYICAL ANGE . >>NYMEALHI
T'>>NGLI ESTIVEDIN Y O SN>>ACEGG
HA
HOHE
COLEONHE
NBO IBL ROCOTOMALEXT.
VE B A AY.IG WAKTUSIAITHI>> NNO
BOAND  CTTHD SACY?E OCTNT GITHER
B
IS NINND BRY.  CBU ST DEV A  WI
ESLL -
ALKI S TWH OCO. SS T Y.VISE AEST
T ONG
R?THSI TT'E.EP>>RAI' BELEACNTUTE
RO HLEE TLI.SAS
IAGOT. W TANP HEEANE
TH TCIT AY- HADTOY US>>
ONTIOU,,OERALECOBORSTISI H HNOPA
BURY
O IT>>REA ESEALA TOTUT Y L YAVTR
HAS  A P'MIST -NGADHA TER BN.MEG
D SDSROISHEO MYBLCAXP Y .IVINMEH
NROMOKET O W YCH  NRS.LITHCKPE P
HA
OUUXOU
AL
ID.
Y TISOLIS T U
CO YTHDE
T HI
EEF O
U R- YRE,PIM I
SA GGERELAOU
ESTBOKE DE HOESTH UETLTEEDIAN AT
LI.HASAOM OESBA PAND P
BOTH TSNG
TAAWANAF
TT O
F ER WND>>CO C A